nice to say oh if you don't like gay
marriage don't get gay married but what
if I don't like children being subjected
to societal pedophilia well then don't
be a part of society all right so this
is the context I breathe another
question today do you think that the
whole push for pedophilia now has become
mainstream at what point does it become
mainstream yeah and how far you know
it's we're not just going down a
slippery it's not a slippery slope it's
like we're going down the slope in a
flying saucer with the cereal varnish
vacation it is romário nice yes
yesterday yesterday gosh it seemed that
was a week ago Mario Lopez he was
attacked because he had the gall get the
stones mind you to say that parents
should be careful about three-year-olds
choosing their gender right he was
forced to apologize
that's insane absolutely insane so think
about that for a second before we move
on to how this relates to sort of
pedophilia in this hyper sexualization
of children how it's become mainstream
think of what that apology signifies
okay he is saying I am sorry for
suggesting that parents shouldn't allow
their three-year-old or four-year-old or
eight-year-old child to make a permanent
decision regarding puberty blockers and
stunting their growth for the rest of
their life I am so sorry I now know
better and I will be more thoughtful in
the future by that I mean guaranteeing
the moral high ground to the opinion
that all children should make permanent
sexual decisions at the age of three and
that's why I have I have no tolerance
for people who apologize on these issues
anymore really if we talked about this
we talk about on Ash Wednesday if people
want to stay in the closet you don't
wanna come out as conservative that's
fine I understand it keep your head down
but do not apologize when you have done
nothing wrong and you don't listen your
view hasn't changed Mario Lopez you
didn't have a change of heart you're
just afraid and it's only going to get
worse because you apologize I have I'm
done with this guy it other transgender
news while we're getting to the
pedophilia that Jessica Yaniv right this
is the person in there there's something
a lot of people don't know here but
let's go to the first this is the person
for people who don't know Marley was
dead to begin with suing places
estheticians for not waxing zzz balls oh
and what if she did that and then my
wife to polish is Johnson you know in in
this day and age was the with the beats
Human Rights Code in the
cainy Newman writes code if someone
identifies as a woman they have to
receive those gender affirming care
services that's the Wow I didn't
understand a word that gentleman was
saying without a clump in Whiteface not
even making an effort there this even
testified at a British Human Rights
Tribunal will it by the way same kind of
Human Rights Tribunal that had Mike Ward
right they wanted to sign him up for a
joke and the story dominated the culture
war while we were gone with even the the
Prime Minister actually the press
conference case you missed it young it's
important i clarify transphobia has no
home in canada and this beautiful and
brave woman she deserves the same
dignity and basic human rights as all
women including that of having her
beautiful scrotum and testicles waxed
without fear of shame there would be a
big check and as Canada's chief
executive let me offer Jessica our
sincerest apologies out of the symbolic
show of unity allow me can outperform
the original services you were so rudely
denies diff mr. Preminger I was told
every piece no no Jessica there's no
need to accept the consolation prize
here actually my lawyer and I we have we
discussed them hey hey please the most
important things in life cannot be
bought or sold
like the dignity of which you were
robbed on which I could play sweat no
monetary value well actually we agreed
upon it and so there's no sense in
trying please please don't
[Applause]
something that people haven't
necessarily talked about yeah Jessica
also under fire for trying to throw a
semi-nude kids pool party where parents
weren't allowed the balls on this broad
and it's unsurprising to me it's
completely inevitable because by its
very nature its sexualizing children
this is a sexual decision this involves
one set we talk about reproductive
rights right at the reproductive rights
of children yeah don't shouldn't didn't
have the right to be protected as it
relates to their ability to reproduce
anything we're actually talking about
reproductive rights yeah every time
it'll push some gender studies trend all
the focus immediately on children why
and let's review this and you might
think this is kind of a fringe tendency
but they have a long history of
sexualizing children pushing pedophilia
so let's go to the brief history lesson
here 20th century okay many famous
academics they argued in favor of
pedophilia in 1977 three Frenchmen they
were put on trial okay for having sex
with kids young as 13 number of French
intellectuals signed a petition to
legalize sex with young children okay
this is important because we've talked
about gender theory all of the biggest
post modernist thinkers in France they
signed it now uh Michel Foucault
non-south Jacques I think it's it was a
jock Derrida he's not fast about leotard
is his actual name sweetheart Simone de
Beauvoir we've talked about Simone
before the list goes on the crazy thing
is by the way the age of consent in
France right they decided this was going
to be the mantle they would they would
kick yeah it was already fifteen they
wanted a compassionate any law regarding
age in an interview about this petition
Foucault said I want to quote him
directly to assume that a child is
incapable of explaining what happened
and was incapable of giving his consent
are to abuses that are intolerable quite
unacceptable so he thinks it's abuse
cannot allow kids to have sex
keep in mind Foucault is my deal to this
day the most cited author in all the
humanity studies across Colorado he is
the he's thought of as the father the
godfather of gender theory itself
Seimone double vote we just talked about
see one to vote a french existentialist
she's the first person to claim that
gender was a social construct serves as
the bedrock for modern gender theory oh
boy I'm starting to see a trend here so
these were the theorists right this is
important our theorists the philosophers
and did you learn in college the janmani
study did you look this was a the guy
who had twins and he raised one as a boy
why don't you study now but I do not
this is important because this again
everything you know about transgenderism
do you say
push the pedophilia well here's why
sorry you have the philosophers the
theory who established it by the way
they still believed there were only two
genders didn't leave that there were 57
like on your Facebook profile only so
crazy hey and there was Neetu Jenner's
then there was in practice the case
study it wouldn't call it a clinical
trial but you've learned about this in
college this is John money he was one of
my twins right he raised one as a boy
one as a girl to prove that gender was
arbitrary we've already covered this one
of the twins was I I came from the one
that was raised as a girl I think yet
committed suicide the other one did not
to be fair died of an overdose of
antidepressants and this is still taught
in schools as the basis of the modern
medical approach to transgenderism and
he had this janmani to say about
pedophilia if I were to see the case of
a boy aged 10 or 11 whose intensely
erotic Lee attracted toward a man in his
20s or 30s if the relationship is
totally mutual and the bonding is
genuinely totally mutual email then I
would not call it pathological in any
way he said that's insane he and he made
them in a point kind of we skipped over
he made them perform sexual acts with
each other on nating sexual acts yeah
incredible and that in and of itself is
sexual abuse the poet Allen Ginsberg I
think we talked about was deported from
Cuba for saying take you yeah member of
NAMBLA oh my gosh yeah to say oh if you
don't like gay marriage don't get gay
married what if I don't like children
being subjected to societal pedophilia
well then don't be a part of society I
know how do you hide three years old
remember people are now used to flying
Mario Lopez AC Slater for saying that a
three-year-old can't decide to change
his gender well second if a kid can
change their gender what why wouldn't
they be able to consent to sex
surely a sex change is a bigger life
decision than just having sex be ready
to understand this it's natural this
would follow suit all right so let's go
to the honorable normalizing pedophilia
this is happening right we normalize it
right right now didn't die out in the
seventies no just I think we have some
overlays here the pedophilia supporting
publications they've been running
stories over the last few years yeah we
actually broke the fact that the salon
pedophile was the one who was actually
currently grooming children and then
they wrote an article that we were
monster yeah but let's go on to how
they've been pushing in a different way
by do I hit a notification bell if you
haven't already because of Scriptures
don't mean anything of course to include
letters could've become such muck let me
get a full Daily Show subscribe on
iTunes for exclusive audio content and
please leave us a rating there um here's
something else has been going on for a
long time
child drag queens yeah okay I think with
some b-roll 11 year old drag queen
Desmond
this is yeah called Desmond is amazing
stripping at a club having money thrown
atom for people who can't see right now
look at this tell me that isn't
disturbing yeah look at this is a boy
stripping and they say there's nothing
wrong with stripping and Men giving him
money by the way I got in trouble at 14
for mowing lawns because of the
violation of the Labor Bureau remember
they were like you technically you're
not supposed to do that it's illegal
what about when they're making it rain
on an 11-0 dress and michael jackson
sailor pants all the lemonade stands
cops have been breaking up around the
nation and the only reason they're ok
with this by the way is because it's gay
can you imagine if it were just a
straight strip club with an
eleven-year-old girl there yeah
whatever occurred right it would never
even if it was someone's fetish they'd
be like hold on no there's other people
here the gay repeatedly they tell us it
has nothing to do child drag queens
nothing to do with sexual or sexuality
but the race is why is one of them a
mascot for an erotic clothing company
lest you think I exaggerate here you go
look yeah houses man of course after
they were called on it they tried to
scrub the word erotic from their website
they just word those pesky words the
some would argue that actually in a
tone-deaf move they replaced the word
erotic with crotchless leather that
doesn't seem like it was well time
imagine for a nine-year-old girl with a
ball gag in her mouth as the face of the
gap erotic clothing store you don't see
it that's really extreme right drag the
drag queen scenario know that that was
trending on YouTube and was supported by
the transgender community at large on
shows away let that drag queens story
time harmless right this is just people
reading the kids it happens at libraries
across the country well except in a
Portland library ended up with drag
queens dry humping children they're the
pictures they're the pictures oh by the
way that guy moonlight to the Scout
counselor what no of course it's not
church kid wouldn't be surprised
drag queens story time Houston ended up
with not one but two sex offenders on
its roster back to Jessica Jessica the
Canadian trans activist a city even the
one who insists that women get their
balls waxed is a human right to sex
weird long with internet in Germany
getting your balls waxed as a woman yeah
turns out tried to host a no parents
allowed topless pool part
for twelve-year-old girls also allegedly
tried to show child porn to underage
girls obsessed about it was talking
about new girls and locker rooms asking
about tampons this Jessica he asked if
it's okay for ten-year-old girls to bare
all in the locker room he asked sorry we
have to bleep this
do you see sin puppy ever to
twelve-year-old girls which by the way I
guarantee you they do they have him so
this is really just to get like he's not
he's not he's definitely getting he's
not asking anything no to what she
doesn't know the answer do you ever see
yourself naked asking he was asking them
the best way to bond with girls he was
devastated by the way he was devastated
when it turned out that they weren't
just parading around naked in the locker
room was really upset by it yeah I don't
know it's not Porky's Jessica Andrews
scenario it's just getting off to asking
questions to twelve girls have you heard
about this in mainstream media anywhere
you've heard about the initial story
right right split this keep in mind
Jessica's explicit that Z is attracted
to females and identifies himself as a
proud lesbian so I'm still angling for
that available striker spot in the u.s.
women's soccer team you might see it
we're talking about mainstream CNN's
Chris Cuomo the DNC pool boy in chief
said that twelve-year-old girls are
bigots if they don't want to look at
grown men's penises there's the tweet I
can't believe that one how are you
supposed to be tolerant of a child
seeing a man's penis like how is how is
the word tolerance thrown in there that
should never happen period right so why
is o and Cuomo was saying she needs to
be more tolerant dad needs to teach her
to of a guy's penis hanging out know of
a boy stripping down and having
cornerstone that I'm a drag queen story
to at least get some dollar bills out
let's have some the history right the
history is this is all founded upon this
the founders of the feast supported
pedophilia all of modern gender theory
look it's him on the Bravo look at John
money look at all of these they are the
most cited of anyone out there they all
supported this they actively signed on
to this they championed this and the
same people the same organizations who
have the ear Darwin of DN C who are
attacking Mario Lopez yeah look at their
platforms they all support this and this
is about as thick as something can get
and this is something I think people
everyone needs to think about here we
talk about a responsibilities as a
society the conversation now was turned
to free stuff a lot right a
responsibility to provide free school
for
health care free tampons but you know
what before we get to the free
commodities that you would like not a
right commodities that you would like to
not have to pay for how do we understand
the most basic societal responsibility
since the beginning of civilization not
Western civilization's by the way unless
you try and call this a racist dog
whistle for the alt-right just
civilizations since the beginning of
human beings the responsibility to
protect the most vulnerable among us
that's why we would send men out and
protect the women and children in battle
right you send out the strong to protect
the vulnerable what anyone disagree that
the vulnerable would include children
yeah if this is as sick as it gets and
it's mainstream and today's left it's a
consistent pattern and how often do you
hear about this right now from the press
go to right now do this do this
experiment go to the homepage at Vox go
to HuffPo go to salon go to the youtube
homepage go to their YouTube heroes
translatable GPT QA AIP activist page is
anyone talking about this jessyca
business will anyone be talking about
this segment I guarantee you they won't
unless it's expressing outrage and
offence over the serial sex offending
[ __ ] profile pedophile sorry
why because I misgendered him that's
what they'll be upset about because
priorities so it's really important just
to understand how this has been creeping
in for a long time the basis for modern
gender theory and how far we've gone and
that's why you don't apologize
Mario Lopez what are you thinking AC
Slater hey there if you like this video
subscribe to the channel or hit the
notification bell do it I'll wait a
second do you hear that little ding it
actually did make a ding sound I just
did it would happen while my mouth was
doing it and you thought it was coming
from your computer so that's fun also
there's some videos playing in these
boxes next to me go watch those you
might enjoy them you might not you don't
care